- Until when?
- Til Wednesday.
- Wednesday.
- Coming back.
- How you doing Boyd?
- Doing well how are you doing?
- Thanks so much, Heather.
- You're looking great.
But yeah, so we all were
hanging out last night
at the Maluma concert, and basically,
I hadn't seen a reaction since Jerome Dark
with this guy right here.
Everyone wanted a selfie.
(laughing)
Every single woman in the
audience, in the crowd,
he couldn't, I literally had to--
- Well, look, when you got a pretty face,
there's only so much you
can do, I mean, you know.
- I don't know about that.
- Life is life.
Like when you got it, that's the way.
That's cool.
- It's not a terrible problem.
- Yeah, no, it's not the worst
thing that ever happened.
- He has all this attention and one thing
I wanna talk 'cause I know
we don't have a ton of time.
- What do you do with it?
- How do build is personal brand
when he has so much going on.
- You work backwards.
The key is to figure out where
you are at this point in your life.
You work backwards from what you want.
Like everything I do is about
buying the New York Jets
professionally and it really helps
when you know what you want.
So to your point, when you
have that much attention,
it's such a big deal.
When you actually know
what you want to happen,
whether that's a TV show,
starting your own media company,
starting a fashion brand,
putting yourself in a position
to get brands to endorse you,
make $50 million a year, marry someone,
like it actually doesn't matter,
it could be anything, start at,
it could literally be anything.
But what I would tell you, brother, is,
and by the way it changes, right?
We're all different than
we were three years ago
and it's gonna change in three years.
But to the best of your ability,
based on all your life and all the,
you know, I know enough to know, like
right now what is it, what's
the chip on the shoulder,
and what's the ambition,
and you balance those,
and then you really can figure it out.
- Yeah, yeah.
So it's like working backwards
from where you started?
- Mm mm.
What do you want to happen.
If I was like, yo (snapping)
I could make that happen.
The question is what would you wanna do
if you could control, like professionally.
- Can I name a bunch of things?
- You can 'cause it'll help.
- Because I'm like very much
like you in a sense, I guess.
You started off as a wine guy.
I started off as a dancer.
And then you jumped and
jumped and jumped and jumped.
And I went from, my jumps were like,
dancer, choreographer,
creative director, actor,
fitness, social media,
branding, these kinda things,
writing, producing, and it's like,
so, for me, I guess when you look at--
- Creative sits at the
center of that for you.
It's all creative.
- I'm very creative and I'm
all over the place with it.
- Right, clearly.
Which is super common
fro somebody creative.
I'm all over the place, just had enough
of not being all over the place
that I was able to build something,
but I have empathy for that.
- But for a brand to go, "Oh
yeah, he's great for this,
"because he aligns with
us because he does this."
They're like, "Oh, no,
he's, God what does he do?"
"He does nine things."
Which is good for me when I, I don't know,
it can be anything from
like acting something.
I can do a million different things.
But it's hard working with brands.
- Do you wanna work with brands?
- Yeah, I do.
But not, like I was telling, not on like,
I've never done and I
probably never will do
like a one off post type thing.
I wanna create companies with them.
I wanna invest time into them.
Because the people that follow
me choose to push follow and
choose to push on the notifications
and choose to comment
and like and write my DMS
and ask me questions,
and really get involved
with who I am and what I
do, whatever that may be.
- You wanna respect that.
- I wanna respect that.
- Me too.
- So I don't wanna just sell out, fucking,
hey, let me, Vayner Water.
- I get it, you're preaching.
- They gave me fucking
twenty grand, here you go.
- You're preaching, I
believe in that so much.
I've never done one branded post either.
Ever.
And I've been offered some crazy ass shit.
- I think too, like, we were talking about
a lot of influencers
have a certain audience.
I think his audience is very valuable
because he's not just
an influencer, right,
it's not just about how
many people follow him,
it's when he's out in a concert.
- [Gary] It's who.
- Who, middle aged women, I mean my mom,
we were at a conference
with all these influencers,
she was, "I just want
a picture with Beau."
- [Gary] Of course, of course.
I get it.
- And those people are
making purchase decisions.
The other thing I think
is great is that Beau
will go out and meet those people,
if he's with somebody from a brand,
and they have the Reddit thing,
he'll be like, hey I'm with this person,
he's not like hey how much
you gonna pay me for this.
He's creating relationships.
I think that's something different
that a lot of people aren't doing.
- I'd rather have the long term,
but also it's like, does it hurt me
to post anything or anybody,
you know what I mean?
Does it hurt if a friend's like
hey can you post this on your story,
I'm like, yeah, I don't
care, it's 24 hours.
It's helps them.
It doesn't hurt me.
And it brings attention to
that person which helps them,
and if I can help someone I can.
But it's like, when we were
out there at SXSW thing,
like Otter Pops, you know what I mean?
The guy was like I know who you are
because my sister in law's a huge a fan.
She runs a dance studio in
Chicago, it's a big studio.
And I was like Facetime.
I was like let's say hi,
you know what I mean?
So we Facetimed her.
She didn't pick up, so we did the video.
I was like, hey thanks
for all the support,
out here and whatever.
But it's just, what does it hurt?
It doesn't hurt me.
- Karma's practical.
- Yeah, even if it's one person.
- You're preaching.
- Yeah, you guys are
really similar like that.
The other thing is he said that he likes
to talk about brands he likes
whether he's working with them or not.
- Smart.
- Similar to like his studio,
he can wear any shoe he wants,
doesn't have to be K-Swiss,
that's the type of
stuff you could be into.
'Cause some things he works
with and some things he doesn't.
- I get it.
Of all the things that you are doing,
would there be something
that if you had to pick one
or you've done, like you've probably done,
this is me guessing,
you've accomplished more
in the dance sphere than you
have in the acting sphere
for yourself.
- Huge, yeah, creatively.
- Do you still have a lot of
oomph for the acting sphere?
- Oh, like if I could snap anything,
it's being not even a
TV star, a movie star.
On the big screen, action, comedy.
- I think that's right,
so I'm glad you said that.
So that to me is how this goes.
Like if we had all day,
that's where this goes.
Now you start thinking about,
see that's where I start thinking about
who do you do pieces of content with, how,
how do we get it in
front of whom and what.
It's literally like, you know,
there's so many ways to do it.
Like getting pieces of content
in front of the right people.
You have a very interesting dynamic
because you have so much
awareness of the marketplace
because you're in such
a white heat moment,
that of a certain age group,
like everybody in Hollywood,
probably if they're over 32,
highly likely, they know of you
and have some sort of thing.
So advantages and disadvantages.
- Super, super.
- 100%.
So I think the way to me is
how do you penetrate your content
knowing that instead of
hoping it didn't exist.
- Right.
- Right?
- To me that's how you win.
You win when you accept it as
a positive or negative, just neutral.
Some people lose their minds,
some people are like fuck that guy.
You know how it is.
- I'm super neutral about it.
If I can stay away from it, I do.
Because--
- Sure, came with so much baggage.
- Yeah, and there's no
need to bring it up.
But yeah, sometimes it's like oh,
he's not gonna get this
just because he had,
you know what I mean?
It's like, or just relationship, friends,
and things like that.
It definitely played
in the music business.
With creative direction
and certain artists
and labels and stuff
that I was working with
far before, and then
it just changed after.
'Cause introductions
I made to that person.
And then they establish, and it just hurt.
So you know.
- It is what it is.
- It's okay, 'cause I move--
- It's life.
- Yeah, and you move on and
you keep going and you brand.
- How old are you?
- About to be 31 next week.
You literally fundamentally
have your entire life in front of you.
It's just crazy, right?
You like lived a life, you know.
- No, no, I know.
Not for nothing, but I
bought a house at 26,
I'm very proud of that,
that was like one of the...
- Where'd you grow up?
- Anaheim.
- Yeah.
- You're an Angels fan?
- Yeah, I am.
- That's awesome.
How old were you in the world
series with the rally monkey?
You were young.
- Oh, I don't know.
- Do you remember it or no?
- No.
- Is that even too young for you?
Angels versus Giants world series.
- Too young.
- 31, you just weren't
into it then, right?
'Cause it's not that long ago.
- Yeah, I mean I'd go to a
baseball game with my step dad
who I didn't love at the
time, but I loved the game,
but I didn't, you know what I mean.
(laughing)
Now I love him.
- Is that right?
- Yeah, 'cause he took care of me.
Like as I got older--
- At the time, you realized what he did.
- Yeah, he was a dick and he was rough.
- But it helped in some ways.
- He's more on my sisters.
And as I got older I was like yeah,
he put braces in my mouth,
he put food in my mouth,
roof over my head, clothes on my back,
and these things that we couldn't afford.
So he really took care of us.
Now I'm like yeah, whatever you need, bro.
I got you.
- That's cool.
- So yeah.
- Alright, what do you
think, while we've got,
I feel like you have so much context,
you have the most context for both of us.
- For whatever reason, I, you know,
there's a lot of people
we could work with,
but Beau is somebody that I
feel like he's a super star,
He's gonna be a super star,
or he is already one in one--
- You just feel like
there's more depth there.
- Yeah, there's depth, and there's talent,
which has longevity, and
not only that but also his--
- You mean when his pretty
face goes away in 30 years,
it's still just gonna be,
it'll be distinguished face.
- He has a good personality.
- And he's real about it.
- Yeah, and I mean I think, everybody,
I think we were talking about,
when you were called the wine guy,
oh this guy's gonna try to do Twitter,
oh now he's doing Twitter,
now he's gonna try to do this,
and it's kinda like, oh well he did this,
so that's what he is, and I'm like, no,
we wouldn't be interested
in doing stuff with him
if I didn't one like him as a person,
two think he has longevity in this space.
- So I like I told her I was
sitting next to this guy on the plane,
and there was a few scripts on the floor.
- Literally?
- Well I mean it's first class and he had
three scripts right in front of him,
laid out on the seats and stuff.
And I was like you gotta read
all those just on this flight?
And he was like at least two.
I'm like good luck.
And that's it.
And he was like what do you
do, and I was like I act,
and he's like oh nice.
And kinda like brushed it off,
and he's like who you with,
I was like (mumbling),
and he goes oh, good (mumbling), great.
So like just having that in
my pocket it's like notoriety.
- That's why I signed
with CAA ten years ago.
- Because someone goes you're
serious, you're talented,
Jason signed him, he must be fucking good.
And Jason signed me personally.
But if I was with Joe Blow.
- You're preaching.
- He's like who's that.
Or he goes, oh cool.
- Yeah, good luck.
- Right.
- Totally understand.
- There's this no space, though, right.
- It's a trade.
- And he didn't do anything for me.
- There's this new space for
like a marketing director
or somebody that basically
doesn't compete with your manager.
- That's what you're
trying to fill, right?
- That's what we're doing.
- And that's--
- And people like him
coming to us to do that.
I think a lot of people are
gonna wanna follow in
your footsteps, right,
even big celebrities you would think
have all sorts of deals
coming to them and they don't.
- They don't or the agents are
not showing them the right
stuff, I totally get it.
- Remember when (mumbling) and you said,
if you want somebody to
advertise on your website,
you pick up the phone and call them
and say hey I think your brand would,
that's basically what we're
doing now with celebrities.
And the ones that are humble enough to say
okay cool let's go, because some of them,
they'll say I don't have
a deal with so and so,
or if Gary doesn't give me a
deal why am I meeting with them
and like I see it all
the time in Hollywood,
these people are really gonna
drop the ball when they see--
- It's called entitlement.
And when you don't come from a whole lot,
if you could stay grounded and
you don't wanna rewrite history
you could stay real humble real fast.
That's the advantage.
- I feel like we keep it at a certain
percent of entitlement.
Certain things--
- Well you wanna be thoughtful.
- Right.
- I don't think it's,
I think entitlement is
you think you deserve it,
and I think what you're talking about,
where you're about to go,
and I've already got a
sense of your energy is
look you need to be thoughtful.
I wouldn't do things that are
in the detriment to me long term.
But I definitely--
- Not comfortable.
- That's right.
- Yeah, but like, (knocking)
knock away to everyone.
If you, call me, I'll meet anyone.
- I think the acting
thing's interesting to me.
I don't have the necessarily any answer.
What I like is that's what you want.
Which leads me to more like,
so I think there's gonna
be a really interesting
genre within Facebook of people making
original films and uploading to Facebook.
Like so to me I think you
can control your success
potentially in the next half decade
without UTA, WME, managers,
I think that there's
a real opportunity and
I think it's gonna come
in the form of independent
films on Facebook that pop.
- So it's funny you say that
'cause Brittney, when she did that thing,
and when she interviewed me she goes,
"So I'm getting a sense that,"
she goes, "So if you got a
big opportunity with Facebook,
"that wouldn't do it for you."
And I was like it wouldn't.
- Makes sense.
I think it's this way,
I don't think that does it for you either,
I think you use the
leverage of that success
to get you the things you want.
- To jump in, right, right.
That makes sense.
You know it's crazy.
- You understand?
- Yeah, absolutely.
Because it's the stepping stone.
People see you and--
- It's just leverage.
If you ask me to predict it,
if you said predict how I become a star,
it's something like that
leads to the other thing,
and then you realize oh shit, I gotta
go back to the other thing.
Will Smith's already doing it.
He's got to 'cause as a
movie star he's not relevant.
- And now he's like how did we
live without him on Instagram?
It's like the funniest
fucking thing in the world.
- There you go.
- And then the whole
thing with Mark yesterday.
- I didn't see it, what's that?
- Oh, like, they were in
Ultra and Mark Anthony,
they were on a boat together,
and Mark was teaching
him how to salsa dance.
- That's awesome.
- It went viral, it was great.
- Of course, of course.
- Probably like 50 million.
- When you have that kinda of leverage.
- Yeah, that's crazy.
So know Peter Berg?
- Yes?
- Alright so I did this thing for Prince
where we said we'll talk about it.
I'm gonna try to get Prince in here.
Like I'm gonna try to
get a few artists in here
just 'cause it would be quicker.
- He has them on speed dial.
- Yeah, I'm very connected
in the artist space.
And Royce is like my little brother.
So he Facetimed me last week and was like
hey can you help me, like
I'm pushing this song,
can you just do a video
to it and I'll repost it,
he's just like I just want good content.
And I was like alright cool,
so we just shot it right
before we came and I posted it.
And Peter Berg wrote me on
DM and we follow each other
'cause I box and I fight and stuff,
and he was like yo I really love
the content you've been doing,
he's like it's really good.
I was like oh thanks, man.
How's Ultra, blah, blah, blah, blah.
But just for him to just go
out of his way and be like,
because even though they're
little snacks of nothing.
- Yeah, but I really think I
couldn't agree with that more.
I genuinely believe that that's
what you should be doing.
- Yeah, I just don't want
to get carried away with--
- And what you don't wanna do is--
- Corny fucking cornball skits.
- I know, I know.
You don't wanna make King Batch content
'cause that's King Batch's world.
- And I love--
- Batch is the best.
No, no, he's the best.
I understand what you're thinking.
Not that that's wrong or right.
That's how Batch is gonna get put on.
I totally get it.
And listen, listen, I
have started spending
a lot of time with the
Rock, and by the way,
the Rock, Will Smith, we're
talking about the, right?
- Same guy, yeah.
But just (mumbling).
- I will tell you that if you ask me,
because of the way you popped
onto the consciousness,
I don't trust Hollywood.
I'd rather you go to the consumer
and then put pressure on them.
(mumbling)
You have a funny version of how
I think about John Travolta.
John Travolta became this massive star.
And then Hollywood said no.
And he had to get lucky
that a ridiculous character
like Quentin Tarantino put him
in a movie like Pulp Fiction
and then it popped, but
had that not happened
the machine said no.
I know nothing about
the machine like that.
I just know humans.
There's an enormous percent of the machine
that looks at you and says
no, I know what you are.
Period.
- And all it takes is one person.
- And there's always one
person in that, got it?
So for me.
You don't need to make comedy
skits with booty girls,
you can make a meaningful
one minute piece of,
you wanna be an action star,
make a one minute fucking
action star video.
See what happens.
Take it down.
Like what, what?
Get some young kid that's fucking at NYU
who's gonna be the next fucking Spielberg,
you catch 'em right, go
fucking jump out of a bridge
or a window, whatever
the fuck you're doing,
somebody made a piece, who
was that kid that showed me,
I don't know how was with
me, some kid showed me
a piece of content where he
like came out of the Instagram.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You've seen some of this shit, right?
- He's huge.
- That's that famous guy, he is--
- He has like 20 million.
(mumbling)
- Yeah, right.
Like his shit is fire.
Like I don't know, do that shit,
like pop out of, be like ra--
- I don't even know how to do that.
- I don't know how to
do it either but like.
- What you do have is leverage.
- Do you know how to do it?
- [Babin] Mm hmm.
- So can we do some--
- You know how to do that?
- Why are you fucking
mailing everything in?
Can we make--
- Why are you being lazy, bro?
(laughing)
- Why are you so lazy, Babin?
- If you really know how to do it,
maybe he'll help you do one or something,
you know what I mean.
- Can I get one first?
- Oh my God, Babin, help us all out.
(laughing)
- Anyway, nonetheless,
you see where I'm going?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Here's what I would say,
you're in control of your content.
Just 'cause skits pop, like me,
when I came out the gate,
I made 22 minute wine videos on YouTube.
The only thing on YouTube
was fucking pirated content.
People weren't even
making original content.
It was all Simpsons clips and SNL and
people just not knowing
what, like it would be like,
this pen, people didn't
know what do, you know.
And I was always told that this
won't work, it's short form.
People forget this
conversation back in 07,
can't make long form video.
Like you could make a, in theory,
you could make a ten minute video,
remind me Babin, on
Instagram, you can post
seven one minute videos?
- [Babin] No, you can do ten.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You could.
- But no one likes to swipe.
- I totally agree, it's why I
don't do any of that content,
but let me say this, nobody likes to watch
22 minute videos on YouTube.
If that first minute of that video is fire
and it looks like a motion picture
and you figured out how to make
the 58th, 59th, and 60th second for real.
- Right, you wanna watch,
well that's like the cop
series with Dave Storm.
Do you know?
- Yes, I know, so to
me, I know Dave Storm,
I don't know the series.
Here's what I would say,
nobody's stopping you.
- Yeah.
- If I were you, if we
were homies for life
and lived together in
this studio apartment,
- Wait, really?
- The first, really.
(laughing)
The first video I would
make is straight to video
and be like I wanna make a 10 minute movie
on Instagram, 10 carousel
one minute videos,
I'm the actor, I need a production
partner, who's the best?
Dm me with a link to why you.
Then I would fucking sit
watch 35 to a 100 videos,
emails, written, whatever, pick somebody,
and fucking make it.
- You know, the good thing about that,
well two things, is one,
I can just call friends that
are actually like directors,
and the second thing is
I can actually afford
to just pay people, so I'm
a little bit more blessed.
- Brother, you're exactly right.
So fucking do that and
make a fucking movie.
Make a 10 minute movie.
- And you know artists, crazy,
like even big artists like
French called me, he's like,
I'm releasing this song called Famous
and the words in it are I
hope you don't get famous,
I'm like influencers, this would be great
for a short content on Instagram.
You know these guys,
they want people to make
content for 'em on Instagram.
You could do be doing
that for every artist
that comes out with a new song.
(mumbling)
- Here's my thing.
Yeah, he beat me to it.
That's not what he wants.
- Royce did it as a favor.
Like when Sophia asked me to do it...
- That would make him a--
- He wants to be a,
he wants to make, he wants
to be on the billboard
staring in Transformers 11
or He-Man one or fucking
the Fast and the Fast
and fucking and that's amazing.
- Or comedy.
- He has to show his acting skills.
- But I think what he doesn't
realize, the white space.
- Right.
- And I'm listening.
Is make an 11 minute movie on YouTube,
make it fucking look
like an 11 minute movie
if you've got peeps like
that and fucking go.
- Yeah.
- I don't know what else to tell you.
King made himself a comedy entity
by making comedy where
people paid attention.
Make an 11, if you think you,
I don't know well enough
but I have a feeling
you can make an 11 minute action scene
or six minute scene, and
I'm empathetic to like
blowing up buildings, I
get it, but don't do that.
Do what you can and
just fucking make them.
Like get everybody, in the
same way that Will Smith
is in essence doing something
very similar to what I do,
he's just a much bigger
star and it's going to work,
be, he was one of the first to really go,
you know The Rock and Kevin Hart have been
playing Instagram smartly,
but Will took it one step even further
'cause he had the humility to do it.
- I've told a couple artists to do that
and they were like I would never.
- He has the humility.
It's ego.
- They don't have anything to prove.
- To themselves.
- When you're in that
car you could be paying
French's song, you know what I mean.
- But honestly it doesn't matter,
all that other shit he
could do on the third post.
You don't mix, you don't mix the two.
Just make a fire seven minute,
13 second fucking drama video,
and just, nobody's stopping you.
You're literally one
seven minute, 13 second,
this person saved the world video
away from having everything you want.
(mumbling)
You do understand that right?
That's real, though.
And the second you realize
you can play outside the Hollywood machine
and you can force it,
that's when everything changes.
I think I'm genuinely gonna be
one of the most influential
people in this country,
I'm never gonna play within
the framework of the game.
- Yeah, you don't have to.
- Nor do you.
Go find those talented people,
go find three other actors,
and set up a fucking seven
minute, 16 second video
that's fucking playing
on Facebook and YouTube
and use your one minute video
on Instagram to push it.
And then break the wall,
make one video where
you're like, if I were you,
based on everything I know now,
I'd be like listen guys, this
is really important to me,
and I wanna do it in a different
way, so I just made it.
And you know, if I've
ever brought you any value
just watch the entire seven, 16 and
like tell one friend about it.
Break the wall.
And then now you've got an
entire audience that's gonna care
and hopefully it's fire,
and then it's sitting across
some fucking assistant
at WME, forget about your relationships,
a different person who doesn't know you,
who's watching and they're like fuck.
- This is dope.
- It's dope.
He's got skills.
Holy shit he looks exactly like
the person I pictured that we need for
the supporting role in this blockbuster.
- Right.
Yeah, yeah.
- That's it.
- So now I have this,
now I'm getting flowy.
- Good.
- One day maybe we could, I
don't know the acting one,
is like you said not your world.
- Keep going.
- But so the reason I
started doing like dance,
just little dance videos,
little comedy, little dance,
here and there on Instagram,
is 'cause everyone loves it.
And I'm like everyone
already knows me as that,
I'll never do a dance job,
but I'll put a minute, 45 seconds
of something that people can
enjoy with something funny.
And within that, you
know and the other stuff
I've been doing, I've been consistent
with it with the content,
it's like I've gained
350,000, 400,000 followers
in the past year, just not
really collabing with anybody,
just doing my own thing
and just being good.
- Quality.
- Right, good quality.
- Good at what you do.
- Right.
So I decided I wanted
to do a dance work out,
DVD, app, whatever you wanna call it.
- I understand.
- So I did like a crazy transformation
of like body, like stupid,
and I was just took
everyone on that journey.
- On somebody's?
- What?
- Who's body got transformed?
- Mine did.
- Yours?
You got tight?
- Yeah, yeah, I'll show you pictures.
And I did it quickly.
Not that I was out of shape.
- When you have muscles
underneath, shit can happen fast.
- Yeah.
- I'm even learning that,
I've got a little bit
of muscles and I'm like
whoa, three good days, like it's crazy.
I've always heard--
- It's the eating that's
the most important.
- It's everything.
- But if you don't have the
muscles already developed,
developing them takes a little bit longer.
I played a bunch of sports
so that was easier for me.
But within this, I took
people on this journey.
- Jesus Christ.
Fucking shit.
How long was that?
- Two and a half, three months.
- Yeah, man, that's fucking awesome.
- You were like eating before then.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'm literally right in
the mix of this right now.
- Behind the scenes, bro.
I wore fucking sweaters and
t-shirts and jackets every day.
- Totally.
- I'm not on camera.
- 100%.
- And like acting stuff,
not one acting job,
I've done a lot of stuff,
like Ray Liotta and I,
we have the same manager,
like our personal manager.
Like I have a lot on my record.
- You're really in shape right now.
- Yeah, I'm in good shape.
- Jesus Christ.
(laughing)
I love it.
He's in shape, bro.
That's a real fucking six pack,
that's not even like fucking around.
- It's not like a pretend six pack.
- Yeah, yeah, that's exactly right.
This is not a pretend six pack.
- Yeah.
- He's like, I'm like,
which of your pictures
do the best engagement on this.
- My shirtless.
- He's like my shirtless.
- Yeah man, I wanna fucking...
- Girls like shirtless pictures.
- They do get a lot of engagement.
- Not only girls like, I'll have,
you know Jesse Toro by chance?
- No.
- He's actually directing
and producing and writing
the whole Nikki jam story.
(hip hop music playing)
- Oh that's (mumbling)
(laughing)
- Dude you need to make
fucking seven minute,
you basically, listen to me.
- I'm with you.
- You wanna be a movie
star, be a movie star,
on YouTube and Facebook and Instagram,
make the content, be in full control,
every story you've ever dreamed up,
because it will work, I'm
telling you right now.
- I'm with it.
- You can deliver one line in one video,
and the right person's gonna see it,
and it will change your career.
- I'm with it.
- You know how this works.
The way, like what did she do?
It's one moment in time.
Like she grew up in a game that was,
there was people that had to say it.
We're all now growing
up in a game where they
the audience gets to say it.
You don't have to get lucky
that somebody said yeah, you.
- Right.
- You get to dance in
the background of this.
That game is over.
- And we get to put stuff out
that people can see people
whether they say yes or no.
- Just fucking make the scene of a cop,
like just do it, just be a bad boy.
Boy Boys Three.
You and fucking somebody
else, like just do it.
Like actually, that's where
you could even instill
some of your actual sense of humor.
You can make one that
just looks like the scene.
You can do it all.
You can make one for a week or two
that's the scene of an action movie,
and show the nine minutes
of that, clips there.
And then the following week
you can just make a spoof
and make pretend that you're
starring in Jumanji Two.
You know what I mean?
You could.
- Absolutely.
- But literally my point of recommendation
is you're putting acting on a pedestal
that's higher than the thing that you,
like what I just watched with you and,
that's incredibly good content.
It's just high quality, done well,
and the kinda shit you would see
on screen, or television, or on a phone.
I think you should just do that
literally asap with acting.
Literally I think, my dream is I go
on your account in three weeks,
'cause he pings me or she pings me,
and I look and the video is you coming out
and you're a waiter and literally
I think I'm watching When Harry Met Sally
and then it says go to this link
to watch the whole seven minutes,
and you just literally just did it.
You have enough scale of audience.
If Berg saw you in that environment,
that would mean something different too.
It should would, brother.
- Yeah, you're right.
- I know I'm right about this.
Just own it, take it.
And to your point, between
relationships and finances,
unlike 99% of people,
you can do it right now.
- And it goes with the whole
I wanna do this, I wanna do that,
I wanna do this, I wanna do that.
- Yeah, but you said if I, that's why,
notice how I, no, no, no,
notice how I made the process.
If I could do anything.
So start with that.
We could always sell 10,000
subscriptions to some,
that's the booby prize.
It's really hard to be Will or the Rock.
- But see I think that too.
I think for me, I go, yeah we could sell,
we could sell five, 10 million copies
at $16 a DVD or whatever.
- You could.
- And in the end I just
fund my own fucking movie.
- Yeah, but, you're, I'm telling you.
- We can do it here.
Now.
- Correct.
It's gonna take you a 11
years to build that thing.
It doesn't happen like that.
You're not posting, you and
your friends are not posting
buy the DVD and you're
selling 11 million copies.
You could sell a lot.
You could make a couple
million bucks even.
But you know what I mean?
First of all, it's not gonna be DVD
that games over, right,
so it's gonna be an app.
App development's real.
You know how it is.
That's why it hasn't happened yet.
Whereas you now, literally as
you're going down the elevator
hitting up the seven best
production people you know,
having a meeting in 48
hours and literally,
like literally filming
in nine days somewhere.
And you're doing it all on spec.
You're making your own film as the gateway
to the next film.
- I'm there, I'm in.
- And it's not a movie like all those--
- I'm sold.
- But you know what I mean, brother?
It's not a movie like the kids
that all made that airplane movie.
It's not that.
You see where I'm going, right?
- Yeah.
- Make a scene from
something you'd wanna make.
- Yeah, and it's bad ass and it's
amazing fighting and action and...
- You know how to do that shit?
- Yeah.
- And you got stunt people and people
that can choreograph it?
Like fucking do it.
- I mean, yeah.
- And then we really, I
mean to be very honest,
then, just like all this
stuff goes viral, right?
Whether it's Will or that
dude that I met in LA,
the guy who's doing the
voice over sports shit,
where he's using like
Crass Bob or whatever.
- Oh yeah.
- This guy's fucking an asshole.
He's doing like, do you see that guy?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Maybe you're the one who now
makes movie content on Instagram.
Maybe you're the first guy that
we're looking at it, is this a trailer,
like, maybe people confused even.
Maybe you make a trailer.
Maybe that's what you're making.
One minute movie trailers.
And then you get really creative
'cause you're just making up shit.
- So for me the biggest--
- I mean literally you do,
so that's what you do, got it?
- Need to find a writer,
'cause I can't write.
- Good, so get a fucking writer,
you know what you're laughing
'cause you know where
I'm about to go next,
literally I think you could sell a movie
to Hollywood in a month,
because you made up a
trailer and it's so fresh,
people are like what is that and literally
you're getting reached out to and like
we wanna buy the right to that.
- I'm with it.
- I can see you get it.
- You're the fan base.
- Alright I'm running super fucking late.
- I'm with you, bro.
- We'll connect soon.
(mellow music)